this lecture is officially called like
the GM's choice of sign alright hello
everybody welcome to the lecture where I
get to talk about whatever I want and
the when I talk about two things they're
kind of interrelated that are pretty
complicated to me but I hope interesting
for everybody now the theme of the
lecture is this that over the last year
or so I've come to understand it that
Fisher Bobby Fisher was not a universal
player and that's maybe for for you guys
that doesn't mean anything for me it's
kind of a big deal because I grew up
studying Fischer's games and kind of
thinking of him as this Universal player
and what I'm gonna try to say tonight is
that the thing that Fisher didn't do
well was he didn't play well with a
space advantage and not only that but he
learned ways to systematically avoid
ever getting a space advantage so it's
this really interesting deficiency that
he learned to work around and we'll see
it gets really weird the work arounds he
he comes up with and maybe just as a
life metaphor for what a workaround is
it's like when you're an old guy like me
a lot of times you you can't remember
things right you can't remember people's
names so when you see someone and they
say hi Jessi and you don't remember
their name you come up with a smile or
some little dodge to try to pretend like
you knew their name but you actually
didn't right that's a typical life
workaround that you get in life and then
over the chessboard there's kind of this
interesting thing when you think about
Fisher and other people where if you
have a deficiency it might be a really
cool thing to just say okay I can't
I can't do it this is the kind of
position I can't play so I'm just going
to avoid it
alright now I'm gonna get into that with
Fisher later but the first thing I need
to do is kind of talk a little bit about
what we mean with the space advantage
because it's actually a very complicated
subject
and one at least for me I find very
difficult to understand and I think it's
something that's developed since Fisher
Fisher's time the idea of a space
advantage in kind of conceptual way that
was different from Fisher's generation
so first of all every player has a
feeling of space right like we all have
a feeling for the initiative for example
even if we don't think too much about it
it's in the back of our head when we you
know if we you easily sack upon and get
some play and you feel good about it
then that's your feeling for the
initiative and in a similar way we all
have a feeling of space and we've all
had positions where we felt crowded but
it's harder to say like what is the
space advantage and it gets really
abstract so what I'm gonna do is I'm
going to present two ways of thinking
about the space advantage I'm gonna
start with this position as a position
I've thought a lot about it this was is
a position that was in this Russian book
from the 70s by Stein that I had never
heard of but Delfin quoted in his new
book on positional play and let me just
go back a couple moves Black has played
Knight bt7
white castles and E 5 would go into a
Kings Indian of course c5 instead this
is actually a terrible move and for me
personally it's interesting because I
remember when I was a kid I had I was
poor and I had to hustle chests for
money on the streets of Chicago there on
the Lake Shore Drive
and there was a hustler there we played
probably hundreds of games with this
variation and I didn't really understand
right I didn't understand why it was so
terrible he played it where should I
start okay so as I was saying the this
position is a position I had many times
against this hustler in Chicago and I
played e5 but didn't understand the
depth of blacks sorrows here and this is
a really good position to think about
and this is the position that this
Russian book by Stein from the 70s uses
now let's first just delve into why it's
so bad at first glance it might not seem
so bad at all but there's a fundamental
crowding happening in the black position
and let's just talk about a little bit
this night is blocked by the other night
this night's blocked by that night the
night on f6 is blocking the bishop
coming out the night on D 7 is blocking
the bishop coming out the bishop on CA
is blocking the rook coming out and the
night on D 7 is blocking the defense of
the d6 bar so it's this real mess and
you say to yourself well why is it
important to do the d6 pawn the reason
why controlling d6 is important is that
you can't play e6 because I can take and
then take on d6 and E 6 would be let's
call it the way for black to at least
open the position a little bit maybe get
a Benoni style position so the
interesting thing is when you really get
into this position is to say Oh black is
actually kind of positionally busted
he's actually in deep deep trouble and
that was a big surprise to me to find
that out and to think about it
so the word that this old Russian book
uses is capacity and so what we're gonna
say for whites advantage is he has the
capacity to maintain this space
advantage and that seems really weird
but think of it like a bucket that you
have to fill if you don't fill the
bucket you won't actually be able to use
your space advantage and black will be
free now that probably all sounded weird
but let me show you exactly what I mean
by the following position it's the same
thing same exact position it's still
black to move all we've done is gotten
rid of this piece this piece this piece
and this piece and the stunning thing
about this position is that now black is
better what that's like
yeah it's truly astonishing and the
first thing to see is that blacks
congestion problems have been basically
fully resolved right the rook is happy
on a because the bishops not there the
knight is happy because this isn't here
the bishop on CA isn't being blocked by
the knight this bishop is happy total
freedom on this diagonal and the whole
time in both positions black doesn't
have any weaknesses now on whites and
his minors don't have the ability to
squish black and in fact they don't have
the ability to cover all the back spaces
the the spaces behind the space
advantage right you have this frontier
up front and you need material to cover
it cover the space in back of your space
advantage and to give you a nice example
here there's several moves of black can
play but the one I like best is b5
and play like a banco gambit and not
only do i think black is better here but
it's just really instructive when you
think about the Benko because the banco
is really geared toward first of all
getting play on the queenside so you
don't get smashed with your central
disadvantage and then your King later
you know whipping in but two because the
banco is ultimately an opening and
people don't realize this at first
that's geared toward an end game black
actually wants an end game and that's
weird of course because whites up a pawn
and you'd say to yourself well you know
normally the business there is to go to
an end game if you're up a pawn okay now
let me come back to Fisher a little bit
first thing to realize about Fisher is
that he is coming of age right as the
what we call the hyper-modern openings
are happening the hyper-modern openings
are the openings where you give your
opponent the center and that was a very
controversial thing at the time and when
you look honestly at old games from the
8th you know the 1800s almost all of
them start either d4 d5 or a 45 and they
go along those lines similar to lines we
still play today but they didn't have
the groom felt they didn't have the
Kings Indian all these openings that we
now play that are hyper-modern in nature
they didn't have so Fischer was exposed
to this and all these hyper modern
openings really are dealing with not
having space right now let me try to say
articulate a different way of thinking
about space that's less abstract and I
kind of think it's how Fischer saw the
game
and in a lot of ways it's the way I
think of it too and let me just say
what's interesting about this fisher
thing is for me anyways it's not just
historical but I came of age as a lot of
other American players studying his
games and there's arguably something
like chess the chess gene of Fischer is
somehow inside of me because I too feel
it's a funny thing I not really
comfortable say playing against the
benoni but I've played the benoni a
bunch kind of uncomfortable playing
against the French and the Kings Indian
to both the openings that give white a
space advantage so let me go ahead and
talk about an opening the groom felled
and use this different way of talking
about space so this this different way
of starting about spaces like this you
say listen we are not interested in
talking about this abstract weird space
thing we're just going to talk about the
question are my opponent's pieces being
made poor if they're poor then we can
talk about specific pieces being poor
and a lot of times with a space
advantage like we have in this position
you could say well the problem is really
that the pieces are poor you don't even
have to talk about space you just talk
about individual pieces and you talk
about their problems okay in the Grune
felt which I have to admit with the
first time I saw this thing say this
position I just said to myself wow
that's great
that is fantastic for white how could
this possibly be a good idea for black
but when you consider it not from the
angle of space but just from the angle
of are my pieces good or bad then you
look at all of black's pieces especially
the minors and you say you know what all
those pieces are active and they are
doing things so black fundamentally
doesn't have a
and so you could say to yourself you
know forget about the space disadvantage
thing we're just gonna talk about the
pieces
alright let me let's look briefly now at
fishers openings for a second and let's
start with the kings in them so Fisher
first of all is the first to really
popularize this move which is central
now to modern theory right you almost
get every single game before Fisher
there's a lot of games played like this
and this is playable but what you're not
doing is you're not forcing the d4 pawn
to decide where it wants to go
whereas knight c6 is going to put the
pressure and make him decide okay so now
let's stare at this position for a
second in a lot of ways this is the
ultimate in space advantage in a
conventional opening right houthis when
you think of yourselves like well what
other openings give such a strong space
advantage it's hard to come up with one
as Grievous at this position and also
using what I would this other way of
talking about space well you can say
this guy is terrible and that guy is
terrible right and it's only when you
start in this King's India where it gets
interesting for black really is when you
start thinking about the pointing of the
pawns that are pointing towards the King
sight excuse me
pointing towards the Kings side ie
declaring to though everybody that that
is his side of the board when you see
that and then you see that this F pawn
is coming and the fact that this poor
King is on the side of the board where
the attack is also going to come well
then it becomes interesting right
so the first point I want to make about
Fisher is this was of course one of his
major openings and clearly he was
comfortable with playing without space
right playing without space now let's
look at his other key opening here the
knight or Lily just a quick aside you
know it's it's fun to look think about
Fisher now actually and what I just
witnessed on the Isle of Man and next
lecture I'm gonna talk about one of
fabi's games and all these new players
they're playing so many different
openings mostly because they don't want
to get caught up in some kind of prep
and Fisher was of this generation where
he actually believed it seems funny now
but they really did believe this they
believed that they had found what was
correct like they knew that like they
knew somehow the truth about what
openings were good and what were bad
okay I want to talk just briefly about
what I think appealed to Fisher about
the nigh Dorf and I want to use it to
talk about this other way of thinking
about space which is it's about
controlling your pieces Fisher played
both sides of this but let's just pause
for a second and what I want you to see
is that white is incredibly ahead and
development and activity but
what black is claiming is that all of
the pieces are fundamentally controlled
like this night when you just map out
it's possible squares right totally
controlled the bishop as well
totally blunted the night as well d5 and
b5 right
so it's this interest very interesting
idea of saying first of all I got extra
center pawn and this pawn isn't working
but on a broader scope and this is the
way I think Fischer thought about chess
was to think about controlling pieces
and trading off the good pieces and
leaving your opponent with the bat
alright now let me move on a little bit
one way I came to understand Fischer's
woes was the falling almost anybody who
writes about Fischer has thought about
it realized that the guy was completely
traumatized by the French defense it was
the one opening that gave him loads of
trouble and it honestly it never made
sense to me until recently but why is
why is the French defense such a hard
thing for Fischer to crack right it just
seems totally weird that the French of
all things were given trouble and
so let me break this down a little bit
he played what I would call theory in
this position Knight f6 B who played
Knight f6 Bishop g5 Bishop me 45 until
1961 now before we talk about what
happened in 1961 there is this period
where I think he hasn't come to terms
yet that he doesn't like the positions
with E 5 let's put on Bishop before you
find why because he's just playing what
to his mind is theory right and I think
Fischer had up to that point just a very
let's call it a clean repertoire where
he was just trying to always play the
best moves and E 5 it's hard to imagine
that a 5 is not the right move here it's
gotta be it has to be the right move ok
then he had terrible results all through
the 50s against this opening and then in
1961 he lost a couple very key matchups
and then I believe is a US Championship
he lost to my future teacher I wasn't
even alive at this point admire madness
who I think he just thought was
completely beneath in which he was but
he won in one of these French games
where you you know you move your Knights
around you do a little dance you
understand the position you keep it
closed and you don't mind the space
advantage and you know the longer the
game goes on and some pieces trade off
the capacity for white to hold that
space advantage can often deteriorate
and it's white who has the disadvantage
with a d4 pawn before point let's say
and black doesn't really have it by the
way this is e v is a great opportunity
to talk about the difference between
central control and space
when you play e5 you you are abandoning
the central fight in an interesting way
this pawn on e6 fights for d5 the d5
pawn fights for efore so black is rock
solid on the two white central squares
and of course it's going to fight for d4
and e5 black on the other hand now
exceed me white on the other hand is
really only a rock on on e5 okay and by
the way I have to admit this didn't even
occur to me until I was much older but
when you consider the this position it
really is a mirror image of the French
and it's funny that I didn't think of it
and I think a lot of people don't think
about that this is a mirror image of the
French because it feels so different it
feels so different because of the
pointing of the pawns because black has
an initiative against the King whereas
in the French what we do is we are
pointing towards the Queen side right
where the King usually doesn't end up he
can but he doesn't usually end up on
that side aboard so it feels different
but it's fundamentally the same
structure it's just a mirror image and
so I think that is one of the key
problems for Fischer facing the French
is that imagine you know view is aware
of it either but yeah he was unable now
what I'd like to do now is just show you
then from 1961 on the weird stuff that
Fischer does to work around his problem
with the French in particular so he
played Queen G for this terrible move
after Knight f6 black is doing
absolutely Fenton
he played a three terrible move
absolutely awful I think he might have
tried Edie at some point famously of
course he played d3 that was his other
work around and what is he doing he's
saying I'll just play a Kings Indian bed
yeah if you're gonna force me to do this
I'll let you try to get a space
advantage and the famous game of course
is Fisher versus magma Zirin
he's 1967 or something like that where
you know we're just playing a Kings
Indian now as white alright
the the sign that the the game though
where I really understood the depth of
this format suffering alright was in the
it's in the candidates match of against
Petrosian in 1971 and but trojan at that
point is flailing and doesn't know what
to do against Fisher Fisher's at the
absolute peak of his game and Petrosian
plays in 96 now the French player like
myself
this is heretical this is terrible don't
ever let me see you do it right it's
just an awful thing but watch what
Fisher does Knight f3 Knight f6 and he
takes the pawn right freeing the bishop
on ca after which black has absolutely
zero problems so to Pete this is like
when I saw and I really was thinking I
was like this is a man who's been
traumatized he's been completely
traumatized by both the structure and
the the concept or whatever you want to
call it of the space advantage okay let
me make a couple more points
one thing about efore players in general
is that they more typically get an open
game then they get a game where they
have space the French is a key example
and another one is this position though
I got a say at the time of when I was a
kid and in Fishers days this was thought
to be ridiculous because you're letting
the bishop out only later did people
realize that then the tempo was amazing
for white and that if black plays c5
that has its own dangers both on this
diagonal and maybe a knight coming
through the d4 square okay so let me
show you one more position that I think
is really interesting for Fischer and
space and that's in this ruie that he of
course played all the time
quick historical note you know guys like
Carlsen are playing d3 and weird stuff
now and when I was a kid and I play d4
and is following in Fischer's footsteps
it just felt like the manly thing to do
to play c3 and the interesting thing was
to my young mind the point of c3 was so
that we could play d4 right it was like
we are playing c3 in order to play d4
now the weird thing about it though is
that in fact no not necessarily
because when you look then at what
Carlson did and let's go and play d3 and
let's just say for kicks d6
and c3 the interesting point and this
goes to the second conception of space
or a different conception of the game
altogether which is that you know you
can if you want you can forget about the
notion of space entirely and just talk
about which pieces are controlled right
so the point of c3 is really all about
saying this knight on c6 is bad right
and this is an entirely different way of
playing the Lopez okay I'm getting
off-track though back then everybody
played c3 d6h three and in Fishers day
when you look over his games
there's loads of this system which is
usually called the chigorin okay Queen
c7 played a gazillion times now here's
this interesting thing that I can read I
have this youthful memory of really
thinking about this position and I would
ask myself well why not d5 why can't I
do d5 what's wrong with that and Fisher
never did it and there's all kinds of
different interesting ways that d5 can
happen for example Knight bTW - let's
say Bishop b7 for example well d5 is of
course a good move here because the
bishop on b7 is cut however Fischer
never did this he never pushed the pawn
to d5 as far as I know he never pushed
upon the d5 and what he would instead do
is let's say Bishop d7 he would play
this position
all the time and the plan was to go
either III or g3 and then plop into d5
or f5 and totally different feel of the
game it's gonna be fast it's gonna be
about tempo it's gonna be open so yeah
really I know just another example of a
position where he always declined to
take the space advantage and the thing
about the space advantage that is so
curious now for modern chess players is
it is very difficult to play with a
space advantage because it's really kind
of like learning to become a jailer in
the sense that you aren't really playing
to kill your opponent you're trying to
play to keep him jailed until he
basically starves right and this
involves like a totally different way of
thinking about the game where you are
constantly thinking about ways in which
your opponent is going to break out of
jail so to that end there's only one
game that I could think of where Fischer
got a space advantage and that was also
in this match with Petrosian I believe
71 and it happens because of let's call
it theory
what Fisher understood from his opening
study was that this Bishop b2 was known
to be inaccurate and the reason it was
known to be inaccurate was because after
f6 white isn't in time to do d4 so for
example let's imagine white had played
III and then f6 well then s6 is not
nearly as strong because d4 and after
Bishop b2 d4 is a thought but it's gonna
get whacked by 85 right so the
interesting thing is that arguably
Petrosian knew or and you could also say
the Soviet team knew about this base
disadvantage I don't know anything about
the insider business with the Soviets or
anything like that but it's interesting
his next move because petrosian's next
move is very awkward and strange I think
I I would guess here for white III and
then if I five d4 and maybe black is a
little bit better but we really have a
fight on our hands instead of a Trojan
play c4 which is really terrible because
now after d4 we're gonna get a benoni
where the moves b3 and Bishop b2 not
only don't help white but they're kind
of just negative like the bishop if
anything would like to go back to c1 now
it's so terrible on b2 all right let's
see how it goes
d3
'if I've III there's different things
that white could play and there are
several moves here that Fisher does that
I think are just pretty strange first
things first I think black could play
knight c6 and just you know and then
just see what White's gonna do because
you know that knight c6 has to be
correct okay so like I said this is the
one game that comes to mind for me
there's got to be others but this is
just the one that came to mind me where
somehow by some accident like this
Fisher found himself with a space
advantage so 97 seems weird knight c6
it's strange it's very strange because
it's obviously in the way of stuff but
okay it's what black is still better
here Knight bTW to castles castles efore
so there's been several things about
White's play that have been strange you
know moving III II for doing this b3
Bishop b2 and then c4 all pretty abysmal
Fischer's next move or plan let's call
it I don't like at all really and yeah
we're going to talk about so first of
all you got to ask yourself well what is
Petrosian thinking when he plays d4 and
the answer is pretty i think easy to
spot the guy wants to play Knight e1 and
Bishop g4 and the simple point of Bishop
g4 is not only are we going to trade our
worst Bishop for blacks best bishop but
also in a space disadvantage you
fundamentally want to trade and
maybe I'll just talk a little bit about
this because it helps under people
understand the space advantage you can
think of it like a let's call it a math
equation for boiling water right
everybody knows what I don't know
everybody anyways
that when you have the equation for heat
density is like a big factor usually Rho
or something like that the Greek letter
Rho is for density and anyways what I'm
trying to say is the more dense the
white pieces are when they're getting
boiled as it were the more difficult it
is gonna be for him to move around kind
of like a cooking pot now so with that
in mind that 91 Bishop g4 is coming I
think this move that Fischer does a six
well I really don't like it and a pretty
well I think an instructive response
would have been to play like this night
a 691 Bishop g4 96 in which case black
first of all fixed his strange night on
being and preserves his good Bishop on
seeing and really makes it difficult for
white to trade off the bishop on g4 in
any kind of advantageous way whilst
leaving this hoarded mess over here
right however let's think about this
position for a second because it kind of
gets the matter of why I think Fischer
found it hard to play with the space
advantage because like I said before the
skill with a space advantage is simply
preventing your opponent from ever
escaping right and not necessarily in
some plan of going after your opponent
in some kind
systematic way we in fact black has no
plan here other than just to keep black
pin down and not to allow them to
relieve any pressure okay let's look at
the game a 691 b5 and the reason this is
a little funny is that black now has the
option at some point doesn't have to be
right away of taking taking an a4 to
free the c-4 square for his night so we
started off with Bishop g4 which takes
Queen tix and Queen CA this is a good
move of queen seeing and this will be
this is a really interesting point that
I that the gelfand book really helped me
understand that at first glance this
queen c8 would seem to contradict
everything I just said about the space
advantage because I was just talking
about how you don't want to trade pieces
so you could say to me Jessie what are
you talking to me about you just told me
this long song and dance about not
trading pieces but what Gelfand noted
that's very interesting is that
primarily when we're talking about the
space advantage it's about making the
minors bad the queen will find a way to
be active as well as the rooks in
general like in this position you can
see there's possibilities for a for to
happen for and like I mentioned see ba
ba for M so the the heavies the white
heavies aren't the ones that we're
really persecuting it's the three minors
who as you can see just visually they're
absolutely awful
okay so black/white could have taken but
he goes back 97 and he just say it's so
interesting to think about it in terms
of let's say my own chest development
because when you look at Fischer's games
let's go back to the Kings Indian just
for a second
once one very non modern thing that he
would often do to meet White's expansion
on the Queen side is he very often
played the move c5 and the idea that he
used in several games was to in instead
of just going for it on the kingside
like you see guys like Nakamura now
doing he would first try to stabilize
the situation on the Queen side with c5
and of course that's what we got here
with c4 and when I was a kid on these
structures I remembered it was always
like I was dogmatically doing the same
thing with playing here and then trying
to crack this point
Yatta Yatta but the funny thing is all
your it's it's it's not terrible but
what you got to realize is you're not
interested in the pawn break per se you
are interested in making the white
pieces terrible and keeping them in a
box and I honestly I didn't get that
forever and I didn't have a coach to
tell me it's like it's not about the
pawn breaks it's not about some Knight
b6 stuff it is about making the piece is
terrible okay 92
Rippey ate slightly funny but now truly
I think a terrible move from Petrosian
here a move I don't understand
rook FC one it's as if he is hoping for
some kind of wildness here on this file
whereas the move rook FB one gives white
every hope not every hope but some hopes
of equalizing we're black now has to be
worried about snip snob and snag hold
gaining the c-4 square and ideally
really he doesn't care so much about a
potential weakness on b3 he cares about
fixing his guys and both both of the
Knights honestly can use that square
potentially the other night too
all right let me show you how this went
this move was strange to me I don't know
where the Queen's going this move also
strange I think he needs to play CB and
a4 that moves kind of strange to me as
well and now he does it but he does it
in a position where it makes no sense to
me because now the bishop is in the way
of the a pawn
again I still want the guy to play a
four
and so bobby was able to achieve this
position after which he is truly doing
great now it might seem like we've
extended beyond the scope of our
discussion of space but I do want to
share one more thing about this gave
that dig is interesting in this position
black can do several things here
he can play Knight a5 for example
threatening Knight b3 he you know in
this position you gotta say either that
black is clearly better or maybe close
to waiting ok
the decision that Bobby takes here is
real interesting as 95 would really be
the decision to play against continue to
play against the two poor minor pieces
but what he does here this transition is
fascinating because what he's gonna
implement now which yeah it's funny with
you when you look at this position
honestly when I look at it it's not
immediately obvious that this is gonna
pay off to me for black but let's get
inside Bobby's head for a second
Bobby is saying that it's the advantage
of the rook and Bishop versus the rook
and Knight which will be significant in
the coming ending and we now call that
advantage we call that the fischer end
game and again and to put it briefly in
hopefully words that are understandable
later you got to learn how to do it in a
practical way and this is a great
example of the fischer ending but I
think the easiest way to understand the
fischer ending is let's through a
metaphor
now in our political culture right the
left in particular likes this some kind
of phrasing like in diversity there is
strength right and usually they're
talking about racial diversity but you
can imagine all kinds of different
diversity education income age all these
kinds of things and if that's true right
that there's strength and diversity
really what you have to say is some
people are able to do one thing and
other people are do a balloon
together they can do something special
and it might not seem like I'm talking
about chess anymore but what I'm talking
about is the Fischer endgame because the
poor Bishop this poor beast only touches
half the board for all of its life
however in the endgame it touches far
more squares than the night the night is
a maximum of eight and this Bishop even
though it's a bad Bishop technically
blocked by the pawns already controls a
massive amount of squares right
so with that advantage of square control
the rook then controls the other half of
the board the it can catch the squares
that the bishop can't see and that
allows the rook and the bishop through
that greater square control to dominate
the knight and the black the white
position in particular I could talk
forever about it but let's just roll
through it and then I'll try to wrap up
vision before dominating the knight
check to the misérable King you can
touch you can hit everything you want
yeah it doesn't seem like we're gonna
win this but watch what he does here
notice that he some players would you
know be willing to trade the rooks no
rook trade this is the Fischer endgame
it seems like we blew it seems like the
Kings offside but Fischer has faith that
the rook will be a monster no trade
now the rooks not allowed back oh man
this is a totally evil endgame look at
that and we're in and it's over so what
one reason I wanted to finish on that it
was a variety of reasons but just to see
that the maestro had this one weakness
but he was also in several areas of the
game the person who took us to new
places not only the Fisher endgame but
just the idea that the bishop was
stronger than the knight okay let me
finish by saying a closing thought that
I think any chess player could use is to
say to yourself of course ideally you
would like not to have holes in your
game right places that you don't
understand or are uncomfortable with
right for example you've all heard the
saying that you should be comfortable
with playing both width and isolated
pond and against the isolated but if
we're honest with ourselves
then maybe you create a opening
repertoire and just an awareness in
yourself that you can't do everything
correctly you maybe you don't play with
the initiative well or maybe you don't
play the endgame well or maybe there's
some other feature of the game that you
find a workaround really like Fischer
did right where you recognize your
weaknesses and it's hard for though let
me just say this about visitor it's hard
for me to imagine that arrogant dude
sitting down one time and saying to
himself oh I have a weakness hard for me
to imagine that guy's saying it to
himself but as you see with like French
and the other openings
never he did at least have the awareness
to say something like I don't like these
positions all right we're gonna take a
short break and then we're gonna go and
do lecture number two
[Music]